they say you should meet at the
restaurant rather than driving together
they say traveling solo to your date
spot allows you to decompress from your
day solo and you'd be surprised at how
something is so simple as seeing your
spouse through a window or like watching
them arrive like saying oh
yeah can like rekindle those first date
romantic little flames you think there's
anything to this I'm no longer stressed
I'm irritated oh god I've been saying
this on this show since we started three
years ago you have
the fights I've like gotten in with like
boyfriends about like I don't want to
talk in the car because you've run out
of conversation by the time you get
there or you're just exhausted or like
you're getting ready and they're just
peeing in the background and you're like
man where's the spice yeah you know
whatever
haha